A mobile task force makes its way through
the Siberian forest.
Snow covers the trees; the only light comes
from the moon shining through the branches.
The commander holds up a hand signaling the
team to halt.
In a small clearing in front of them is the
creature they’ve been searching for.
It appears to be part-deer, part-human.
The creature howls in pain as it rips the
skin from its body.
The SCP agents watch in horror as the creature
reaches its arm high into the air and plunges
a knife into its stomach.
It doubles over in pain and stops screaming.
The creature pulls the knife from its midsection
and stands upright.
Blood splatters across the shimmering, white,
snow.
It turns towards the mobile task force and
slowly walks toward them.
“Help me,” the creature whispers.
“I need you to save me from what’s inside.”
It collapses to the ground.
The mobile task force secures the creature
in a containment vehicle in preparation for
further examination.
This is SCP-1068-RU - Shell of God.
When they arrive with the creature to an undisclosed
SCP Foundation site location, Dr. Belkov is
put in charge of learning more about the entity.
When SCP-1068 first awakens in its containment
chamber Belkov is watching from behind a two-way
mirror.
The creature walks up to the mirror and examines
the countless scars and stitches that cover
its body.
SCP-1068 shakes its head and gingerly runs
a long finger along the fresh wound where
it stabbed itself earlier.
It glances around the room as if looking for
something, then turns back towards the two-way
glass.
“What time is it?”
it asks its reflection.
Dr. Belkov knows that the creature is talking
to him.
It may not know who is watching him, but it
knows there is someone there.
Dr. Belkov pauses for a moment.
What harm can it do to tell it the time? he
thinks.
Belkov pushes the intercom button and speaks.
“You’ve been in there for almost six hours,”
he says into the microphone.
SCP-1068 looks startled.
Its eyes open wide as it scans the room again.
“You need to let me out of here!”
it shouts.
“Quickly, or you all will be in danger!”
The creature starts to bang on the glass causing
Dr. Belkov to take a few steps back.
There is fear in its eyes that terrifies the
doctor.
Belkov tentatively walks back towards the
intercom button and pushes it.
“I am not sure it’d be safe to let you
out quite yet my friend.
Why don’t you tell me what’s going on?”
“There is no time!”
SCP-1068 screams.
“I can feel him coming.”
Just as it finishes the sentence SCP-1068
stumbles backward.
Dr. Belkov looks on in horror as the creature’s
stomach begins to expand—as if something
is pushing on it from the inside.
A set of claws rips through its skin from
within.
Warning lights begin to flash in the observation
room.
The temperature around SCP-1068 has plummeted.
The fluorescents in the containment chamber
start to flicker.
The howls of the creature are accompanied
by the screeching of something else.
Whoever is trying to crawl out of SCP-1068
is fighting hard to complete their task.
SCP-1068 swings the knife tied around its
wrist into its hand.
It begins stabbing at whatever is trying to
burst out of it, causing blood and skin to
be thrown across the room.
The creature opens its mouth and lets out
a cry of pain.
This goes on for several minutes before whatever
is inside SCP-1068 retreats back to where
it came from.
SCP-1068 stands in the room panting.
It opens the satchel at its waist and pulls
out a bone needle and string.
It meticulously begins to sew up the wounds
from the knife.
Dr. Belkov watches.
Panic fills him as he slams the intercom button.
“What the hell was that?” he asks.
“That, my dear friend, was my brother.”
With those words hanging in the air Dr. Belkov
furiously jots down notes.
He needs to learn more.
Belkov runs out of the observation room and
grabs two SCP agents to accompany him into
the chamber of SCP-1068.
He needs to examine the creature and find
out what is going on within it.
When Dr. Belkov and the two agents enter the
room, SCP-1068 shows no signs of aggression.
Although the creature has a masculine voice,
its chest and other human parts seem to be
female.
Its entire body is covered in stitched-up
wounds.
However, Dr. Belkov can see into one of the
fresh punctures that SCP-1068 made to itself.
The creature looks at him and shakes its head.
“You have no idea how much danger you are
in,” it says.
“We want to help you.
My name is Dr. Belkov and I work for the SCP
Foundation.
Can I examine that wound?”
SCP-1068 looks at the doctor, considering
his question.
“I have nothing to hide.
But be aware, you might not like what you
see.”
Dr. Belkov nods his head.
He holds up a flashlight and shines it into
SCP-1068’s wound.
What he sees gives him pause.
There are no bones, organs, or muscles of
any type under the creature’s skin.
The space inside the body seems to be infinite.
Perhaps it is a deep void to another dimension,
Belkov thinks.
As he gets closer to the wound he can feel
a cold breeze leaving SCP-1068’s body.
“Do you mind?”
Belkov asks while holding up a thermometer.
The creature shrugs indifferently.
Belkov tries to take the temperature just
beneath the creature’s skin, but it is so
cold that it causes the mercury in the thermometer
to freeze.
The doctor furiously writes notes into his
log.
SCP-1068 finishes stitching up its wounds.
The creature sits back in its chair.
“I am sure you have some questions.
Let me start by introducing myself.
I am Ay Neil.
I come from an ancient tribe that inhabited
the area where you found me many moons ago.”
“So, you’ve been around for a while?”
Belkov asks.
“That is correct.
I lived with my seven brothers and a small
tribe of humans deep in the Siberian Arctic.
My brothers and I were wiser and more skilled
than anyone else in the tribe.
We eventually became deities to them.
I was the patron saint of seamstresses and
a warming shoulder for the people.
Unfortunately, not all of my brothers were
kind.”
“I think I see where this is going,” says
Dr. Belkov.
“In my experience, there is always one who
betrays the rest when it comes to beings with
special powers.”
“You may be more right than you know,”
says Ay Neil, shaking his head.
“For a long time there was peace and harmony,
but then the Great Grief happened.
My brother, whom I will not speak the name
of, was the master of the hunt.
He believed that since he provided life-sustaining
sustenance for everyone he should be the ruler
of the tribe.
I was closest to this brother, so he asked
me to join him as his second in command.
I refused.”
“I assume that probably didn’t make him
too happy,” says Belkov.
“No, it did not.
He was furious and slaughtered everyone in
the tribe including the women and children.
Then he began to kill his own brothers.
He butchered our whole family and then eventually
came for me too.
I could not match his combat skills, but I
had a plan.
We battled for many nights; I waited for the
perfect opportunity, and when my brother lunged
at me in blind rage and frustration, I knew
it was the moment I was waiting for.
I ripped open my stomach and he fell into
the void.”
“I think I’m going to be sick,” gags
Belkov.
“Are you telling me that thing inside you
is your brother?”
“That is exactly what I am saying,” sighs
Ay Neil.
“How long has it been in you?” asks Belkov.
“Too long.
That is why I have sought the help of the
SCP Foundation.
My brother cannot escape; otherwise, the whole
world will be doomed.”
Dr. Belkov leans back in his chair and whistles.
He can’t believe what he is hearing, but
at the same time, this wouldn’t be the craziest
thing he has witnessed at the Foundation.
“Now you must leave the room,” says Ay
Neil.
“It is almost time for my brother to try
and escape again.
It happens every six hours, and if I do not
stop him, he will destroy us all.”
Dr. Belkov and the agents leave the room.
Once the door is closed Ay Neil begins to
scream.
He looks down at his stomach as his brother
rips through his insides.
An audio recorder in the room picks up a conversation
between Ay Neil and his brother as they battle;
they are talking in their native language.
Several days later Dr. Belkov retrieves the
audio and sends the recording to the linguistics
department to be decoded.
For several days Dr. Belkov watches Ay Neil
battle his brother every six hours.
The brother rips through the stomach lining
of SCP-1068 with its claws, Ay Neil stabs
him using his knife, and after the bloody
battle is over, Ay Neil sews himself up and
rests until the next attempted escape.
Dr. Belkov sits in the observation room flipping
through his notes when he comes across a report
from the linguistics department.
He had forgotten all about the recording,
but as he reads the translation, his heart
sinks.
“What in the name of God?” he says out
loud.
The conversation that was recorded during
the battle didn’t make any sense.
A muffled voice could be heard saying
“think it over, fool.
Because of your selfishness, we will all die.
The cycle must not be broken.
Let me be reborn.”
This was clearly the pleading of Ay Neil’s
brother.
But it is the next words that truly terrify
Dr. Belkov.
“They believe your lies.
Isn't that enough for you?”
The next sounds that the recorder picked up
were the stabbing of flesh and screams of
pain.
Dr. Belkov shakes his head.
So, Ay Neil is lying about something?
Belkov thinks.
Could he be evil?
Perhaps the characters in his story were switched…
what if Ay Neil was the one who slaughtered—.
Before he can finish his thought there is
a loud crash as the two-way mirror shatters.
Standing in the opening is SCP-1068.
His eyes have changed; now they are filled
with evil.
“Oh doctor, I’m sorry it has to come to
this, but I can’t let you live when you
are so close to the truth,” says Ay Neil.
The creature steps through the opening into
the observation room.
Dr. Belkov screams as the knife plunges into
his stomach.
Now watch “SCP-2273 - Major Alexei Belitrov
(SCP Animation).”
Or check out “SCP-610 - The Flesh That Hates